[Musica]
io solo una femminista
ok forse qualcosa pensandoci lo potevate
intuire di solito il capello corto da
qualche indizio dunque forse un'altra
cosa che poteva farvelo notare poteva
essere il mio abbigliamento normale
infatti oggi sono in tenuta da evento vi
va di lusso normalmente mi potreste
immaginare in una di quelle foto vecchie
un po sfocate con file e file di
studenti vestiti in malissimo con
pantaloni a zampa che neanche elvis
presley e con la mano paralizzata in un
unico gesto quello del peace and love
dunque solo una femminista quindi oggi
vi potrei parlare di parità diritti vi
potrei parlare delle donne ma se ci
state
e oggi vi parlo di grease facciamo
subito un sondaggio chi è che ha visto
grisa almeno una volta alzi la mano
dico almeno una perché io sfioro le 27
per chi non avesse idea di cosa stiamo
parlando
eccoci qui è il 1978 ed esce uno dei
musical più apprezzati e famosi di tutti
i tempi
la storia è semplice ci troviamo negli
us è chiaramente attorno agli anni 50
quando la gonna a ruota e la brillantina
nei capelli erano d'obbligo negli stati
uniti la storia inizia col cambio di
vita e è quello di sandy una ragazza
australiana che si trasferisce negli
stati uniti nella nuova scuola fa subito
amicizia perché si mostra spontanea
amichevole molto aperta verso gli altri
e nella prima conversazione con la sua
nuova amica
l'argomento è solo uno l'amore
difatti racconta di questa cotta
folgorante avuta durante le vacanze
estive
lui un bellissimo americano dolce con
lei lei in paradiso sfiora il cielo con
un dito
tutto regolare fino a che la ragazza non
rivela l'identità dello sconosciuto il
suo nome
danny zuko shock generale le mandibole
si schiantano per terra perché beh
perché benni è il playboy della scuola e
il cattivo ragazzo è il bono più bono
che ci sia lo vediamo le amiche di sandy
sono scioccate non riescono ad
immaginare che lui sia il pezzo di pane
descritto ci spostiamo di scena e nel
mentre c'è questo convivio femminile
anche i ragazzi si ritrovano dopo
l'estate e per ragazzi intendiamo danny
e tutta la sua crew ma che lui racconta
di questa storia ma in chiave un po
diversa poche chiacchiere
quando sandy e danny si incontrano a
scuola lui e con i suoi amici e sembra
uno sconosciuto
la tratta male sembra che non gliene
freghi nulla
volete il gran finale dopo non so quanti
tira e molla
i due si rivedono alla festa di fine
anno e li vediamo come non li avremmo
mai immaginati danny con la giacca della
scuola da bravo ragazzo e sandy vee
potevamo immaginarlo tacco 12 pantaloni
di pelle aderentissimo trucco marcato e
capello cotonato una canzone iconica you
are the one dérives conclude la storia e
i due innamorati ritrovate a questo
punto hanno finalmente la persona che
desideravano non c'è qualcosa che non
quadra però voglio dire va bene che c'è
il e vissero per sempre felici e
contenti ma a che prezzo
per quanto io ami grease so colonna
sonora e battute a memoria in quelle 27
volte in cui l'ho visto qualche
difettuccio glie l'ho trovato infatti
vediamo nel film che i protagonisti
fanno tanta fatica essere loro stessi
devono sempre adattarsi o uno standard o
un altro loro come noi sono camaleontici
quasi come se ci fosse perennemente una
sfida per vedere a chi si adatta meglio
il premio è solo uno non essere lo
sfigato di turno e parliamoci chiaro se
essere lo sfigato vuol dire non avere
amici vuol dire essere preso in giro
anche solo respirando sfigato non lo
vuole essere nessuno
io credo che il picco più alto di
necessità di adattamento lo si raggiunga
tra medie e superiori
mamma mia la media terrificante il
medioevo della mia vita
lo definirei non ero proprio in fondo
alla piramide sociale però ha più o meno
bazzica voli i motivi sono tre molto
semplice uno era un po in carne e con in
carne non intende o sovrappeso con il
carnet intendo che le mie cosce si
toccavano dove ci doveva essere lo
spazio per forza ii
avevo due tronchi di pino silvestre al
posto delle sopracciglia e tre non
potevo permettermi il quantitativo base
di vestiti di marca necessari per essere
qualcuno mi sentivo sempre in dovere di
dover piacere alla mia classe e quindi
ero preoccupantemente fissa sulla
bilancia chiedevo di continuo ai miei
cose che in un mese probabilmente non
avrei neanche più guardato per questo
che per me sono stato un periodo
veramente buio non poter essere me
stessa mi dilaniava però non si sa
perché non si sa per come una mattina mi
sono svegliata e mi sono detta ma chi se
ne frega
guardando in faccia questi standard e ho
iniziato a essere me stessa però c'è da
dire che non solo alle medie le
superiori dobbiamo adattarci tutta la
nostra vita è così ed è universale
perché che tu sia uomo donna lo devi
fare
vero però che universo femminile e
l'universo maschile hanno regole diverse
prendiamo la figura della donna
prendiamo senti come se mi sembri è
bionda magra alta bella
in una parola perfetta però a detta così
sembrerebbe facile definire un ideale
basta pensare a una qualsiasi modella è
così o ci nasce niente noi ragazze ci
mettiamo l'anima in pace e in buona
parte però no l'ideale deve essere
qualcosa alla portata di tutti se ci si
impegna abbastanza
dunque è truccata sì ma non troppo
perché delle di gaga ne abbiamo una e ci
basta e avanza magra si ma non troppo
perché vogliamo anche delle curve e le
ossa vanno ai cani ma la linea fra
formosa e grasse e molto stile quindi
attende una donna che essere versatile
deve essere adeguata deve essere
spontanea socievole ma mai e dico mai
aggressiva perché agli uomini non
piacciono mica le donne che parlano per
sé e che non hanno bisogno di chi le
difende o non è così
stiamo parlando solo di percezione ci
viene detto che all'uomo piace questo e
non quell'altro che se non ti fai
lazzaretto ovunque sei un orso grizzly e
così non vai da nessuna parte
ma chi ci dice che sia vero non sta
tutto in cosa è bene e cosa è male ma in
come ce la raccontano esempio concreto
io non mi depilo le ascelle
sì l'ho detto non mi depilo le ascelle
perché dopo anni di cerete dolorosissime
mi son guardato ha detto ma chi me lo fa
fare
quindi ho appeso la ceretta al chiodo e
addio pelle liscia effetto seta mi
aspettavo sguardi di giudizio e critici
tutti i giorni però vi dirò la verità
sono state più le persone che mi
dicevano che facevo bene che altro non
sono qui a negare che mi sia arrivato
all'orecchio anche qualche e ma che
schifo ma non è femminile non è igienico
però meno del previsto e se questo è
quello che viene richiesta alle donne
per ragazze ne han da tutt'altra parte
giovani voi dovete essere danny zuko
esino benni perché tanto belli lo
dobbiamo esser tutti simpatici ma avete
un vantaggio potete sottolineare le
debolezze altrui per far sì che non si
vedano le vostre ed ecco qui subito il
problema per voi la vulnerabilità è
vietata perché dovete essere forti dei
matches però così è facile aggrapparsi
alla rabbia come valvola di sfogo perché
se uno non può piangere perché
altrimenti non è uomo se uno non può
parlare dei suoi problemi perché
altrimenti fa chiacchiere inutili da
donna allora mette su un muro è arrivata
la goccia che fa traboccare traboccare
il vaso tutto crolla e si incanala in
rabbia
se siete fatti così siete sistemati nel
mondo che ci vogliono far credere che
voi siate fatti così che sia naturale
che se una cosa innata ma pensandoci
perché perché è una persona si dovrebbe
auto sabotare reprimendo tutto e
rischiano di esplodere
sta tutto incominciano educati in più
per la questione della percezione le
donne così teoricamente vanno in
visibilio no
teoricamente dovere la parola chiave in
queste situazioni dobbiamo perché è di
buon costume
dobbiamo perché altrimenti come ti
rapporti con gli altri
dobbiamo perché così ci si creano meno
problemi ma è davvero meno complicato
facciamo uno sforzo gigantesco sembrerà
un'utopia ma proviamo ad immaginarci una
realtà in cui non ci sono ruoli che non
ci appartengono da recitare dove l'unica
prerogativa è il rispetto per se stessi
e per gli altri
quanto sarebbe più facile adesso come
adesso ci sembra una cosa fuori
questione infattibile perché per
mantenere la facciata sociale ci sia
messi comodi comodi in una confusione
che non è nostra è standardizzata e
uscirne è pericolosissimo ma se lo
faccio io
se lo fa la mia migliore amica se lo fa
il mio compagno di classe la mia
professoressa mia madre se lo facciamo
tutti
arriva un momento in cui non c'è più
nulla di costruito dove l'unica cosa è
accettare noi stessi e gli altri
lo ammetto forse qualcosina di
femminista in tutto sto discorso cielo
ho messo però chiamiamolo così o con un
altro nome
il concetto è sempre quello e non è non
condivisibile se ci lasciamo da parte
tutti quei preconcetti che ci hanno
inculcato la vita è semplice forse anche
griso sarebbe durato di meno dieci
minuti scarsi un cortometraggio ma
quante ne avrebbero avuto in meno sandy
denny e compagnia
ora sta a noi decidere se vogliamo
rimanere dentro le scatole di stereotipi
in cui ci hanno chiuso o se ci va di
uscire di vedere com'è realmente il
mondo e magari di incontrare le persone
che non erano nella scatola con noi vi
propongo una sfida una cosa per tutti
noi proviamo a smontarlo quel muro a
cavare mattone per matto
proviamo a mostrarci più vulnerabili
ragazzi e meno perfette le ragazze da
lunedì per esempio se siete tipi tutti
d'un pezzo che non sono abituati ad
esprimere bene le loro emozioni andate
da un amico e ditegli che gli volete
bene o abbracciate lo invece che quella
solita pacca sulla spalla ragazze parlo
con voi se la mattina non avete voglia
di truccarvi perché lo sappiamo che il
lunedì mattina alle 7 l'ultima cosa che
vogliamo è truccarci che tanto gli occhi
stanno chiusi andate a scuola senza
fondotinta senza siro precisa sistemate
senza pensare a quell'unico brufolo sul
mento per ché io ve lo assicuro di quel
brufolo alla fine della giornata non
fregherà niente a nessuno tentar non
nuoce
e se così possiamo sperare di arrivare a
stare meglio con noi stessi in primis e
poi col resto del mondo beh perchè no
grazie
[Applauso]